coût qui doit sortir du cabinet après
une lourde opération
aujourd'hui il fait quelques examens de
contrôle apple avec l'épidémie de covile
19 l'équipe de ce cabinet vétérinaire a
dû revoir son organisation
les actes non indispensables et
certaines chirurgies ont été reportés
des activités qui représente en temps
normal 25 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
on s'est mis à prendre des rendez vous
toutes les demi heures y compris pour
les prise d'aliments les gens devaient
appeler pour venir chercher leurs
aliments on a mis n'est pas nos salles
d'attentes on a de manière à ce qu'ils
aient jamais plus d'une seule personne
en salles d'attentes avec une seule
personne qui apporte l'animal on évite
de trop touchée où que ce soit même les
caisses de transport des chats on évite
que que ça traîne un peu partout on est
on leur donne une place est sur la table
de consultation et ça reste sur la table
de deux consultations des infections
après chaque consultation le sol du
cabinet nettoyer trois fois par jour et
les effectifs ont été réduits mais comme
beaucoup de soignants c'est le matériel
de protection qui pose problème
on s'occupe pas trop de nous dire
comment on s'est débrouillé un peu par
nous-mêmes pour
pour tout ce qui va et hygiène je sais
que la mairie avait eu raison elle a
donné des masques aux autres commerçants
ouverts il paraît que la région
ile-de-france va nous faire parvenir via
les mairies des masques mais on les
attend encore avec le déconfinement les
équipes ans repasser à des horaires
d'ouverture classique philippe et bras
estime que son activité sera touchée
pendant encore quatre à cinq mois
depuis le 16 mars une dizaine d'animaux
sont soignés chaque jour au lieu de 30
pour simba le chat du cabinet par contre
rien n'a changé